Сергій Олексійович
ви визнали незаконним президентом
україни губернатор донецької області
охарактеризуйте підвезення ситуацію з
нашої точки зору збільшилося
кількість важкого озброєння системі
вчилася кілька сашка займання систем
залпового в ньому збоку Росії
території україни україни
і за допомогою цього тяжкого не за
за допомогою цілого школа зброї не
значиться місця значиться наш обраниці
лише збройні сили
побоюйтеся теж не і ви боїтеся афтор
змінюватися протестував його за допомогою
росії вморив мій біль я вважаю що
знову сепаратист цієї обожнюючого слова
сепаратист абсолютно втрата лу
актуальність на вигляд погрожуючи реальну
ситуацію маємо бойовиків-терористів
коли сьогодні моєму бойовики терористи
вікини євро мати вона ми україни так ось
три хоче закуповувати і годинник на україни я
втиснута ще ми зможемо забути шануй
наук hanoi захист маріуполя адже можна
повторно не пеклі років excel бойових
можливого вторгнення додаткових сил
бойовиків
яка ситуація бішкеку за згодою
біженців на донеччині сьогодні донецької
області близько шести на сьогодні у донецьку
та області приблизно 63000 внутрішню
переселених надзвичайно це дуже велика
цифра зараз жаль вже зараз нажаль
вже настають школу дні дні та рівнем
створенням nls забезпечення людей
харчування малий
аліментарним диплом цінові викл і які
ду ви даєте ви вирішила ти малюками з
цівка а і центральної володієш вчилася
позначаючи але щік flash закінчився
консолі звичайно що випустили закінчився
як належите до тих об'єктів залишайтеся
і дав йому в дорозі на рахунку самостійності
так звані новоросії фото реалізації
України .
я читаю які всі громадяни України
обожнюю я
всі храми діани україни ще харчування
територіальної цілісності за Аліна
петля південь воронню cct досі дана kia
не погані дні та шкіра українець буду
боротися за нашу територію нашу
територію
як починаєте європейський союз як
висловлює європа робот досить буду
допоміг ти ви вирішите з конфлікт поки є
тільки політична допомога ніяка
фінансової україни явно вища політично
доку moroz
фінансові бити ринки ми поки що не
утримав і
ямою на вазі з химери та анонсу що
найближчим часом дійсно подіємо
оснащений великою годиною європейські
інститути чув хвалять рішення то
виділяти матеріальну допомогу assess
the suite аполітичні піт ринку там та
чому періоди активізації потім знову
за спокійно бо як я розумію європа i was
with the cage що милася, а сів
конфлікту
їм хотілося від 3 і турботи та на збір
татул води і без рішення ті та головний
проблеми в Європі стабільності спостерігаю
жадібні державою головній проблемі
проблеми в Європі стабільності жодного
держави не буде Німеччини грати цю
роль краю негайно звичайно ж
Німеччина
самого початку відігравала особливу роль
адже випадково негайно сама початку
вигляді хавала us кута його роль я
зрозумілому і ось ясна за чіпа якісь
економічні інтереси навіть не
мачин та али потрібного з виглядом це ще
одному коротич несвободи демократичні
цінності значного шукай за економічні
преференції хочу з різного ним сюди
ти вибираєш статую капіталу у розмірі
10 тисяч доларів і сутністю провини
то вид по бо будучи видну
краще в витратах загрозі алла буду мама ти
свободу то spoke у Європі
ось будемо мати вільний будемо мати
спокій і в Європі тому до цього
потрібно такий вже тазу ціле потрібно стало
це сам там ще ми знаємо ще бізнес не
матч і не лагодити диск напали to kill a
політики цифра ховають однак знайти
компроміс і тут їх but in нету війну
науки досягла опозиція всіх політики так
сьогодні мати до народу погляду на типу де
адже ще бувають себе на сході України
сьогодні харчування внутрішнього конфлікту в
україні не варто я за зовнішні за groza
від розуму нам необхідно гуртом ви вирішити
цю проблему загроза і ми повинні спільно
вирішити цю проблему всяку за інтерв'ю.